[Music]
on this Wednesday night promotions and
demotions the Prime Minister unveils his
new Inner Circle what a team
who's in who's out of cabinet and what
difference does this shake-up really
make
The Soaring price of rice why it's
become a hot commodity prompting Panic
buying what's really out there oh my
gosh the claims made at an American
hearing on UFOs
plus she was provocative powerful and
polarizing
[Music]
National with Donna Friesen good evening
and thanks for joining us prime minister
Justin Trudeau made sweeping changes to
his cabinet today about two-thirds of
his top MPS have either been shuffled to
new portfolios or completely removed in
an attempt to reboot a government ahead
of the next federal election there were
several new faces in the crowd and some
key absences as Trudeau lined up
alongside cabinet ministers for the
ceremonial family photo today those out
of this new cabinet include some of
Trudeau's best-known ministers former
public safety Minister Marco Mendicino
and former Justice Minister David
lametti are two of the seven who have
been cut replacing them are all
newcomers to Cabinet including Arif
varani who will replace lametti and
become Canada's new attorney general
we'll talk about why all this matters in
a moment but first Mackenzie gray takes
us through the changes in tonight's top
story
[Applause]
it's the group Justin Trudeau hopes will
change the political Channel and win him
the next election this is the team that
is going to be able to continue the hard
work rolling up their sleeves and
delivering for Canadians to do that the
Prime Minister has made a staggering 30
changes to cabinet with a renewed focus
on the economy thank you
Anita Anand who's defense for the lower
profile treasury board
joining up with new housing Minister
Sean Frazier to complement the existing
economic team in direct response to
conservative leader Pierre poliev's
focus on housing and inflation we
have for the homes the
for a growing country I Ritchie valtez
an emotional moment for one of the seven
new additions Richie Valdez sworn as a
new small business minister
along with a reefer run replacing David
lametti as Justice Minister after his
surprising removal Terry Beach gets the
newly created and Loosely defined
Citizen Services portfolio I met my
Deputy Minister about five minutes ago
she handed me a piece of paper with a
whole bunch of bullet points on it but
I'm about uh less than an hour in so I'm
going to get fully briefed 23 the
changes today internal swaps the biggest
Dominic LeBlanc in charge of
establishing a public inquiry into
Chinese interference at Public Safety
House Guest Saint on Janet Heritage
shall be tasked with getting the tech
Giants on side with the new online news
Act
and Mark Miller set to take over at
immigration leaving Crown indigenous
relations I am sad
uh it doesn't mean that that my
relationships that I've built with
indigenous uh leaders and just members
of communities are going away only seven
ministers kept the same job and despite
all the changes the Prime Minister
believes things are running smoothly is
today's changes in admission that things
have not gone well for your government
in 2023 on the contrary I'm excited
about this team and I'm excited about
the work we're going to be able to do
together but the polls would indicate
otherwise the Liberals are now 10 points
back from the conservatives according to
Abacus data their worst position at any
point during Justin Trudeau's tenure as
prime minister Donna okay Mackenzie gray
in Ottawa thanks
cabinet shuffles happen in every
government and it is the prerogative of
the Prime Minister to decide who goes
where it's not always obvious though to
Outsiders why some moves are made for
some analysis or Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson is with me Mercedes
what stood out to you in this cabinet
overhaul
well Donna certainly a reset but there
are some things that aren't apparent to
insiders either including perhaps one of
the most surprising moves of this
Shuffle that was the moving of Defense
Minister Anita Anand to the treasury
board and replacing her with Bill Blair
Anand had expressed a personal
commitment to addressing sexual
misconduct in the military and that file
is far from complete this is also
changing the channel in the middle of
the war in Ukraine and before a major
policy review that will chart the future
of the military is released Blair was
also seen as struggling when he was the
public safety Minister and critics say
that his appointment doesn't exactly
Scream the government's commitment to
culture change nor is he seen as high
profile by some military leaders a more
predictable move and a key one is
Dominic LeBlanc who is now coming in as
what I call the minister of everything
he will keep his current job which is
dealing with the provinces but is also
going to add on what has been an
incendiary file for this government
public safety dealing with everything
from the future of the RCMP and ceases
to of course the anticipated possible
inquire three into foreign interference
a certain Hot Potato file and of course
the mishandling of this file and other
Public Safety files is what pushed out
his predecessor Marco Mendocino
Mercedes critics say this is just a
shuffling of people that it won't change
much when it comes to how the Liberals
govern and what they deliver or fail to
deliver what's your sense of that
Donna this was really about a total
reset for cabinet and you don't see this
kind of overhaul unless the Prime
Minister feels the status quo isn't
working and that feeling is backed up by
the polls the Liberals have been
trailing the conservatives in
consecutive pools they're under a lot of
pressure on the affordability file with
housing and with inflation plus a series
of high-profile political missteps and
Pierre palia the conservative Leader's
messaging is gaining traction especially
in a changing political environment this
is what he had to say earlier today
his government is a failure
it's funny though
the one Minister who's responsible for
these failures didn't get moved and that
minister is Justin Trudeau
Donna the shuffle puts plenty of
enthusiastic new political faces in who
don't have baggage but for it to be
anything more than a cosmetic facelift
the Trudeau government will have to put
policies in to match the Prime Minister
has left some highly criticized
ministers in their files including
Christian Freeland and of course there's
a lot of the same senior decision makers
behind the scenes
okay Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
there's some sad news about a woman who
pioneered roles for women in Canada
former senator Pat Carney has died
Carney was the first woman business
columnist for a major Daily newspaper
and after her election as a conservative
MP from BC in 1980 she was the first
woman in every post she held including
minister of energy international trade
and president of the treasury board
Carney was 88 years old
now to the impact extreme weather is
having on food India has banned the
export of certain kinds of rice a
stunning move for a nation that is the
world's largest exporter of rice heavy
rains wiped out Paddy fields and the
Indian government says it must protect
the domestic supply of rice as Mike
drulay reports has already set off
unnecessary Panic buying including here
in Canada
Sergey mangalthu had a feeling his small
Toronto store was in for a rush on Rice
as soon as India announced it was
Banning the export of small and medium
grain rice he set a limit of one bag per
customer
go out and come back because we put one
one per limit and they come back or they
send their friend or they send the
husband in so that we don't know them
and when that didn't work he says some
got aggressive here is the money give me
the rice forcing him to take the
extraordinary measure of kicking
customers out of the store
Panic buying has set in video from Texas
shows customers climbing store shelves
and buying as much as they can fit in a
shopping cart and that's partly
contributed to a surge in prices The
Benchmark Thai white rice is now trading
for over 500 a ton up over a hundred
dollars from pre-pandemic levels so we
are expecting many many countries to run
out uh rice is is is the most important
food ingredient used in the world 3.5 to
4 billion people rely on rice to support
their their diets India instituted the
ban to keep domestic prices from
increasing but the supply issue relates
to weather alternating flood and
drought-like conditions in Asia have
hurt production Thailand the world's
second largest exporter is only getting
one crop this year and Vietnam says it
will curb exports over the next few
years to ensure domestic food security
and while concerning Canada gets the
majority of its rice imports from the
U.S and the most popular Indian rice
Basmati is not affected by the ban but
Panic says Savannah charlebois has
proven to be contagious protectorism
hurts everyone on Earth and as soon as
you see a government Panic it really uh
creates a ripple effect around the globe
Royal Kerala foods for one is doing its
part by not feeding into the friends
easy while hoping for the ban to be
short-lived microlight Global News
Toronto
tonight nine Mediterranean countries are
continuing to battle wildfires as
searing heat and towering Flames sweep
across parts of southern Europe and
North Africa in the Greek Capital it was
42 degrees today an exhausted fire Crews
have battled about 600 wildfires in
Greece in the last 12 days wildfires are
also burning in Algeria and into Tunisia
forcing thousands of people there from
their homes Crystal commencing looks at
how this unfolding climate crisis is
affecting people
there's no Panic in the ranks but the
men know with the Flames at their feet
they're running out of time we fight we
fight everybody all the people they
fight the simple people the the
government they are several party but
for nothing I believe we fight for
nothing
government officials say only a small
portion of Roads a hugely popular island
with tourists was destroyed by fires but
for those who have lost their
livelihoods the line seems out of Step
my restaurant are not everything it's
take a fire also my mom's house
and my house in the village climate
scientists working with the world
weather attribution initiative studying
the latest heat wave in Europe and
subsequent fires in near real time blame
human-caused climate change
Palermo Italy people made terrifying
Journeys to get to safety west of Lisbon
Portuguese fire Crews and volunteers
worked Tuesday night to Tamp down Flames
threatening a national park and fires
along algeria's Mediterranean Coast led
to the deaths of at least 34 people
Algerian civil Protection Services say
15 fires have been burning across eight
regions
this forest ranger section chief says
calmer conditions are helping compared
to Monday the World Meteorological
organization reports Europe is the
fastest warming of its regions warming
twice as much as the global average
since the 1980s all the more reason why
the European union says it's moving to
double its aerial firefighting capacity
we are in the climate crisis it's
already here it is uh not unexpected the
scientists have been telling us about
this but the new planes won't arrive for
two years at the earliest leaving people
and Wildlife across the continent to
rely on each other to survive in ever
more frequent extreme conditions
Crystal commencing Global News London
they put their lives on the line to save
others coming up gratitude for First
Responders in Nova scotia's flood zone
thank you
in Nova Scotia the search is still on
for one person missing after the flash
flooding last weekend
the bodies of three other people have
now been recovered two children and a 52
year old man when the water was at its
peak dozens of people were rescued
including firefighters who were working
to save others Mike Armstrong has their
remarkable story
aftermath of the storm the storm doesn't
necessarily help you understand just how
bad things got there were three rescues
at this spot including two firefighters
who were Swept Away the video was shot
by Jason Ripley with he says his hands
shaking there was just this one moment
where
standing there in the water and there's
thunder and lightning everywhere and I'm
not a great swimmer and I'm thinking
holy what have I got myself into and
then you just you push through it
flash flooding that did this damage was
destructive and deceptive people didn't
know it was coming
this couple stayed in their home too
long and only got out with the help of
their landlord and a firefighter one
short mistake on our part are the people
that rescued us we could have been gone
no the next door neighbor stayed even
longer and now knows that was a mistake
I wouldn't have made it without the
firemen Kimberly Gillingham was being
helped through a meter of Rushing Water
when she and the firefighter fell into
this hole and were Swept Away the
firemen kept a hold of me and if he
didn't I wouldn't be alive like he held
on to me so tight thank God
and uh
it's just a crazy
one of the things you hear from people
is that as bad as the loss of life was
and it was terrible there's no question
about it there's almost shock that it
wasn't even worse
I think it would be very hard for the
general public to comprehend
the magnitude of everything that went on
early Saturday morning and later into
the day well the rescues were too quick
for there to be actual official numbers
it's likely in the hundreds but there is
appreciation Gillingham will have
surgery on a leg next week and she also
has a firefighter she has to thank Logan
hope
God sent me some hope
Logan hope it was pretty hard it was one
of definitely the hardest thing I've
ever done in my life well hope credits
his crew with saving his life in what
was a day no one involved will ever
forget wow and everyone knows could have
been worse Mike Armstrong Global News
Windsor Nova Scotia
[Music]
claims ahead the U.S government
information about UFOs
[Music]
oh
this terrifying moment happened in New
York City this morning a high-rise
Construction crane struck another
building then crashed down on Manhattan
streets sending people running for their
lives at least six people have minor
injuries including two firefighters who
responded a fire had broken out inside
the Crane's engine compartment fire
officials say the heat weakened a cable
carrying around 14 metric tons of
concrete and that triggered the collapse
the cause of the fire is being
investigated
there was an unusual and unworldly
Hearing in Washington today U.S
lawmakers heard from a whistleblower who
claims UFOs are not only real he says
the U.S government has evidence and is
hiding it no proof of that has emerged
but as the number of sightings of
so-called unidentified aerial phenomena
soars it's fueling a push to make the
public fully aware of what the U.S
government knows Jackson prosco reports
dozens of Close Encounters there's a
whole Fleet of them have been reported
but never explained oh my gosh we're
gonna uncover the cover-up if you
believe the testimony to American
lawmakers the truth is not only out
there it's in the hands of the U.S
government I was informed in the course
of my official duties of a multi-decade
UAP crash retrieval and reverse
engineering program a former Air Force
intelligence officer claims the U.S has
secret knowledge of vehicles that defy
explanation UFOs or what the military
calls unidentified anomalous phenomena
have you met with people with direct
knowledge or have direct knowledge
yourself of non-human origin craft
yes retired major David grush testified
the U.S has not only recovered craft but
in some cases their occupants though he
admits he hasn't seen it himself
biologics came with some of these
recoveries non-human and that was the
assessment of people with direct
knowledge on the program I talked to
rush was flanked by two Air Force pilots
who say they've personally seen things
in the sky they also can't explain if
everyone could see the sensor and video
data I witnessed our national
conversation would change if the hearing
was meant to solve the mystery it only
deepened it with more details than not
left to the imagination I can't discuss
that publicly once again I can't discuss
that publicly I can't discuss that in an
open session the Pentagon denies claims
of a cover-up some of the sightings have
been ruled out with less interesting
explanations like weather balloons
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence and it is a long
walk from triangles in the sky you this
must be aliens without firm answers
those who've witnessed uaps argue there
needs to be more government transparency
over what's known about the unknown
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
[Music]
remembering Irish singer Sinead O'Connor
there are a few voices that cut through
all the noise Sinead O'Connors was one
of them and there's sad news about her
today she has died at the age of 56.
rebellious uncompromising and courageous
she was an exceptional Talent able to
sing in a whisper or fill an entire
Stadium her family gave no details on
the cause of death O'Connor was open
about her mental illness and was
devastated by the loss of her son a year
ago he